merci la parole et à monsieur guillaume
larrivé monsieur le premier ministre
l'europe s'enfonce un peu plus chaque
jour dans le chaos migratoire depuis le
1er janvier ce sont déjà plus de cent
cinquante trois mille personnes qui sont
entrées en europe via la méditerranée
c'est une hausse vertigineuse de 558 %
par rapport à l'année dernière
rien n'est maîtrisé rien n'est contrôlé
les frontières extérieures européennes
sont une fiction pour tenter de contenir
la vague berlin et bruxelles
regarde aujourd'hui vers ankara puisque
la turquie détient l'une des clés du
problème migratoire mieux coopérer avec
ce grand pays est sans doute nécessaire
mais tout lui céder serait une faute
une faute historique monsieur le premier
ministre ouvrez les yeux ce projet
d'accord n'est qu'un marché de dupes
le président de la république a tort de
rester silencieux le président de la
république à tort d'accepter l'ouverture
d'un chapitre de négociation monétaire
qui relance le processus d'adhésion de
la turquie à l'europe
le président de la république a tort
plus encore d'accepter la perspective
d'une libéralisation des visas qui
signifierait la libre circulation de 80
millions de turcs en europe ce serait
une folie
monsieur le premier ministre au nombre
des députés républicains
je vous appelle à faire entendre la voix
de la france est à défendre l'intérêt
des français nous vous demandons
solennellement de refuser le chantage de
monsieur erdogan
nous vous demandons de dire non à la
libre circulation des turcs en europe
nous vous demandons de dire non à
l'adhésion de la turquie en europe
monsieur le premier ministre prenez vos
responsabilités votre responsabilité
personnelle est engagée dit la vérité
aux français
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls et le député
guillaume larrivé la france lors du
conseil européen de cette fin de semaine
reviendra une nouvelle fois sur la crise
majeure que l'europe connaît celle des
réfugiés et qui peut emporter l'europe
j'ai l'occasion de rappeler quels sont
les défis de l'union et celui ci est
sans doute le plus important
il prétend leur public portera trois
messages fondamentaux
le premier message c'est celui du
renforcement du contrôle aux frontières
extérieures pendant trop longtemps on a
oublié que schengen pour fonctionner
devait reposer sur deux principes sur
deux jambes schengen c'est bien sûr la
libre circulation des personnes
c'est un acquis bien sûr à l'intérieur
de notre espace mais schengen c'est
aussi le mécanisme qui doit permettre de
contrôler les frontières extérieures de
l'europe sans contrôle de ses frontières
extérieures
il n'y a pas de shangai possible et donc
du coup c'est l'europe et sa
construction qui peuvent être mises en
cause or trop longtemps ce second point
n'a pas été traité à notre demande sur
notre proposition la commission a fait
une proposition fin 2015 pour créer des
garde frontières européens une des
mesures pour assurer cette sécurité
un accord est prévu et c'est long
reconnaissons le pour la fin de ce
semestre et la france
il travaillera bien évidemment de toutes
ses forces parce que c'est la seule
manière de retrouver la maîtrise de
l'espace schengen est la seule manière
de donner une chance à l'avenir de
l'europe face à cette crise c'est
d'appliquer schengen dans toutes ses
modalités et la france et l'allemagne
sont engagées sur ce point là ensemble
le deuxième message important de ce
conseil la tête de mettre en place une
coopération efficace avec la turquie cas
il faut cette coopération avec la
turquie de la turquie comme le liban
comme la jordanie sont confrontés à
l'afflux
des réfugiés cette coopération est bien
sûr indispensable mais il peut pas y
avoir le moindre chantage je l'avais dit
ici même à la suite du sommet union
européenne turquie du 7 mars dernier la
france à l'occasion de ce conseil de
cette semaine fera valoir trois points
lors du conseil européen joue est précis
parce que votre question n'était cette
coopération doit pleinement respecter le
droit international et le droit européen
la turquie a pris un engagement de
majeur qui est de reprendre sur son
territoire tous les migrants irréguliers
arrivée en europe mais nous devons nous
assurer que cela respecte en tout point
les exigences de la convention de genève
et le droit d'asile en particulier cette
coopération ne doit entraîner aucun
engagement supplémentaire pour la france
et je veux être très clair nous avons
pris la décision d'accueillir 30 mille
personnes
c'est notre objectif est ce notre
promesse c'est ainsi monsieur le député
que je conçois pour ce qui me concerne
et pour ce qui concerne le gouvernement
un engagement politique et morale c'est
indispensable
c'est respecter le droit d'asile c'est
respecter aussi les engagements que nous
avons pris pas plus pas moins
enfin je veux tout particulièrement
insisté sur ce point
cette coopération ne peut pas se
substituer en aucun cas aux cadres
établis par la relation entre l'union
européenne et la turquie
c'est vrai sur la libéralisation des
visas le président de la république l'a
rappelé samedi dernier comme pour les
négociations sur l'adhésion ou sur tout
autre sujet nous sommes très à l'aise
sous ce quinquennat
un seul chapitre a été ouvert je veux
rappeler le nombre de chapitres vous le
connaissez de toute façon qu'ils ont été
ouverts sous le quinquennat précédent
c'est à dire 5 le troisième message
majeur de la france lors du conseil
européen
ce sera la solidarité à l'égard de la
grèce
c'est essentiel et la france il veille
également il est donc essentiel que le
conseil européen et tous les pays
doivent être convaincus de cela apporte
tout le soutien nécessaire à la grèce et
ce soutien
ces trois choses une aide au
fonctionnement des centres d'accueil de
migrants les fameux hot spot qui sont
indispensables et nous le disons le
président république bernard cazeneuve
ou moi même depuis plusieurs mois une
aide humanitaire aider la grèce c'est
aussi honorer ses engagements
en terme de relocalisation des réfugiés
sur son territoire sur le député la
france fait son devoir
la semaine dernière nous avons accueilli
58 une nouvelle personne besoin de
protection sur notre territoire et nous
allons continuer dans le respect des
engagements que nous venons de faire
mais avec un contrôle très précis de ce
que nous accueillons sur notre
territoire
chacun doit le faire mais chacun aussi
doit le savoir
voilà notre feuille de route chacun doit
mesurer qu'à travers ces crises ce sont
finalement deux approches et finalement
deux conceptions de l'europe qui sont en
jeu soit assumé ses responsabilités au
nom de l'indispensable solidarité entre
membres d'une même union et rechercher
ensemble des solutions efficaces et
réalistes suffit pas de proclamer pas
d'ouvrir nos frontières
pas de dire qu'on va accueillir tout le
monde parce que cela peut mettre en
cause le projet européen lui même soit
être partisan du chacun pour soi et les
réfugiés pour les autres et là c'est la
fin du projet politique de l'europe ce
n'est pas cela l'europe ce n'est pas ça
l'europe que nous voulons et la france
se battra bien évidemment pour cette
première approche qui permet de
construire toujours ce magnifique projet
quel projet européen merci monsieur le
premier ministre la parole est à
monsieur